Bob's with us in Colorado Springs
Colorado hey Bob how are you I know how
you are yeah how am i that's the
question there you go man not going to
help Dave I've heard you talk a number
of times about your your views on credit
cards and I not really heard or I and I
can't get my mind around why I view them
actually as an investment where they're
paying me to use that for the month I
never pay interest on them I get you
know I get points or cash back or all
kinds of stuff so I I mean I just don't
understand why it's such a bad thing to
use them I'd like to hear you to address
that sure absolutely
well the thing is this um you're
probably not going to stop using them
after this conversation but I'll address
the question anyway okay uh I would like
to know yeah the the reason is really
simple I've met with thousands of
millionaires and I have never met a
single millionaire that says by the fact
that I'm ripping off the credit card
company with one month's worth of
interest on the amount of my purchases
and I got Discover points back or
airline miles back that's what made me
wealthy I've never heard that ever right
because it has never occurred that's why
I've never heard it it's mathematically
impossible right and so you're playing
around with a bunch of snakes acting
like you're doing something
sophisticated and it's not sophisticated
you're just playing with snakes you've
gotten away with that you hadn't been
bit yet because you're very disciplined
and very careful and you're obviously a
smart person intellectually and so
you've pulled it off but you're not
you're not building wealth as a result
of this nobody not even not even close
not even close it's not even a good tool
it's just a gimmick and so I mean it's
the whole process is just a joke is what
it comes down to and on the other hand I
have met and now I'm not saying this is
you cuz it's not you but I've met
thousands and thousands tens of
thousands of people who have had their
lives ravaged by credit cards now I
don't know I don't think that's going to
happen to you because I think you're
pretty disciplined I get
I will grant you that I will stipulate
that in the conversation but but overall
all I see is downside so basically you
know you know I had a I had a relative
who smoked uh you know two packs a day
and it finally killed him at 86 right
and so he used to laugh about that he's
like you know I smoked two packs a day
my whole dadgum life and it killed me in
86 and he's like in other words
cigarettes didn't kill him his old age
got him right and so it's not there in
the world but does that mean that
cigarettes are okay because he got away
with it no it doesn't it still means
it's a stupid idea they still kill you
they cause lung cancer they shorten your
life they give you bad breath everything
else I mean there's no upside to smoking
only a downside and that's what the deal
is here there's no upside to this the
upsides a joke 78% of the airline mouths
that's that's eight out of ten of them
are never redeemed and if you try to
redeem them you have to fly in the back
corner of the latrine and your spouse is
on four and you change planes sixteen
times to get somewhere and you end up
spending four days of your time as if
that's not worth anything screwing
around with some half-butt airline that
doesn't work and you know how you get
you know you know you know you get
$10,000 for the points you spend a
million dollars on the credit card
that's 1% I mean that's just dumber than
crap you know you should you know you
spend $100,000 on the credit card to get
$1,000 for the points all that effort oh
like crap just to get a thousand bucks
you could have made a thousand bucks in
your sleep man
if you'd have just been smart about
something else so the problem is there's
just no upside and on top of that when
you use plastic credit cards tons of
behavior studies indicate like multiple
behavior studies indicate that you spend
more when you use credit cards than when
you use cash or even a debit card that
have a card you spend more than you do
with cash cash is the least because cash
when you spend it activates the pain
centers of the brain and causes you to
spend less money um you know you just
again multiple studies indicating this
probably the most famous one was done at
MIT and the study was published in
Carnegie Mellon magazine and so on you
know he you just just have to think it
through personal finances 80% behavior
to win with money is 80% behavior so to
engage in behaviors that have only
downside and no upside is a ludicrous
process if you're trying to build wealth
because you are not whipping there but
Bob you are not kicking there but you
are not winning some kind of big
financial game you're not going to have
an extra million dollars because you've
done this when you retire I mean you
might have an extra ten thousand dollars
but you spent fifteen thousand dollars
worth of time screwing with it trying to
keep them from biting you because they
are snakes it is their business it is a
multi bazillion dollar industry and they
do not make marketing mistakes they do
not put products out that they do not
make big money on they're not evil
they're just better at making money then
you aren't messing with them that's what
it comes down you may beat them on the
short term but if you factor in the
value of your time if you put any value
on your time at all you're not winning
not even close early but you're welcome
to try it's okay but that's the
reasoning you want it enough there it is
you spend more and you're not winning
that puts this hour that I Ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar income
you